[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
service pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation la lutte contre la récidive
mise à l'épreuve
il existe aujourd'hui 104 services
pénitentiaires d'insertion et de
probation les spips en métropole et dans
les outre-mer
près de 25 ans après leur création la
commission des lois a souhaité apporter
un éclairage sur leur activité dans leur
rapport Marie merci et Laurence haribet
insistent en premier lieu sur la
nécessité de poursuivre l'investissement
dans les spips en veillant à garantir la
pluridisciplinarité des équipes les deux
rapporteurs se réjouissent que les
effectifs des spips soient passés entre
2014 et 2023 d'un peu plus de 4000 à
6700 agents en équivalent en plein
travaillé et que la prévention de la
récidive soit désormais placée au cœur
de leur mission
ces transformations se traduisent par
une diminution du nombre de dossiers
suivis par chaque conseiller
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation malgré l'augmentation du
nombre de personnes détenues et de
personnes suivies en milieu ouvert
le renforcement des spips a également
accompagné la montée en puissance de la
surveillance électronique qui a vu le
nombre de mesures triplées entre 2010 et
2022 la commission relève aussi que les
spips se sont investis dans la lutte
contre la radicalisation et dans la
lutte contre les violences
intrafamilales la commission des lois
recommande de poursuivre les
recrutements afin de se rapprocher du
ratio moyen recommandé au niveau
européen de 60 personnes suivies par
conseiller pénitentiaire d'insertion et
de probation contre 70 environ
actuellement la Commission estime par
ailleurs nécessaire de veiller à la
pluridisciplinarité des services afin
d'assurer partout un accompagnement
social de qualité
les rapporteurs souhaitent ainsi un
effort de recrutement rapide d'assistant
de service social et de psychologue en
outre elle souligne la nécessité de
disposer dans les spips d'un personnel
administratif bien formé afin que les
conseillers puissent se concentrer sur
leur cœur de mission en second lieu
Marie Mercier et Laurence haribet juge
nécessaire de renforcer les liens des
spips avec les acteurs du monde
judiciaire et les partenaires extérieurs
les rapporteurs recommandent ainsi par
exemple d'étudier la possibilité de
transférer de nouvelles tâches
s'assurées par le juge de l'application
des peines au directeurs pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation
d'expérimenter une permanence du SPIP
auprès du tribunal correctionnel
d'améliorer les échanges avec les
services intégrés de l'accueil et de
l'orientation et avec les conseils
régionaux
elle recommande de relancer le
partenariat avec les missions locales en
concluant une nouvelle convention
pluriannuelle enfin pour faciliter la
mise en œuvre des politiques de
réinsertion les rapporteurs invitent à
ouvrir un accès contrôlé au numérique en
détention
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]